hi in this video we'll be talking about
several antibodies isotypes now isotypes
are basically sub classification of
antibodies based on their heavy chain
and the right chains now we are talking
about several classes of antibodies such
as IgG IgE IgM IgA etc so in this video
we won't be kind of focusing on the
structural aspect of it yeah of course
the structural aspect is important and
that reflects to the function of it but
in this video we will be mostly looking
at what antibodies are most abundant in
our body what are their functions and
how they're biologically relevant first
talk about IgG so if we talk about all
the antibodies IgG is almost 75 percent
of all of that so that makes it the most
abundant antibody in our body
importantly enough IgG can cross
placental barrier and it can go to the
newborn so when the baby is developing
inside the mother's womb its immune
system is not mature its immune system
is still forming at that situation
mother derived i GG is the source of its
immunity so that is why I Gigi is very
important other than these functions IgG
can also fix complement and also be take
part in complement mediated attenuation
processes so in that situation IgG is
super important and its complement
complement fixation capability is pretty
high next we talk about i GM now in
terms of molecular weight
IgG IgM is the bulkier one and also the
membrane bound b-cell receptor is
basically IgM now but the secret at IG m
is basically pentameric and kind of
Auriga more of these membrane bound
monomers now the question comes why some
secreted version is like
a pentameric whereas a membrane-bound
version is monomeric it turns out the
difference between the secreted antibody
and the momentum on antibody is in the
transmembrane domain in the
transmembrane domain is only present in
the membrane bound form which is
basically b-cell receptor but when the B
cell gets differentiated into plasma
cell and secrete an antibody the
secreted IgM don't have this membrane
bound domain so that's why it can be
easily secreted don't get tethered to
the membrane and also with other JH ends
it forms a pentameric structure now IgM
is also very important in terms of
complement fixation it has huge
potential of complement fixation because
it has so many para tubes right now IgM
level spikes just after antigen exposure
I mean in fact the ITM is the first
antibody to be produced after any
primary and kitchen exposure so that is
why I am is also very important after
IgG next we talk about ITA
IgA is basically our dye Marik kind of
structure you can imagine two monomers
are linked together by a Jane and it is
mostly found in secreted fluids and it
can exist as dyma mostly but also it can
exist as tetraman now IgA iga can be
found in secreted fluids like breast
milk
saliva tears mucus etc so we just try to
understand the process of this process
and by an example of trans psychosis the
trans cytosis is a process by which
several protein can get endocytosis from
one side and get transported and
exercised from other side and that is
how it can cross a silver barrier so you
can understand in breast milk the IG a
antibody is basically secreted so how
does it happen
so if we look at the milk ducts
so we would see there are epithelial
cells and the lumen so what happens is
the plasma cells secrete antibodies
which are IgA in nature and they kind of
go and bind to poly igr receptors on the
epithelial cells now poly IG receptor
binding to the IgA leads to its receptor
mediated endocytosis as a result it gets
internalized and from the other side it
can be exercised and released into the
lumen I mean where the milk is actually
getting produced and with that it can be
secreted in the environment right now
coming to IG e IG e level in the blood
is the lowest so it's like constituting
like 3% of all the possible isotopes
found in human body now normally IgG IgE
level is less but some people have
abruptly high IgE levels and those
people are termed as a topic and they
are like sensitive to allergic responses
so in a moment we would see what is the
role of IgE evoking allergy so it turns
out let's say this this human is getting
affected by the pollen grains so when
the pollen grain enters his nasal mucosa
and the dendritic cell or the macrophage
is encountered the pollen grain they
would eventually allow activation of the
T cells and these T cells would
eventually allow the activation of the B
cells nearby now these B cells would
differentiate soon to become plasma
cells now the plasma cells would secrete
IgE by that time the mast cells are also
also getting primed now the mast cells
has IgE receptor so whenever a second
time the individual is getting exposed
to the allergen the IgE produced
deadtime binds to the IG receptor of the
mast cells and allow the myself to be
sensitized and D granulate in the second
time right and degranulation of the mast
cells
smooth muscle contraction vasodilation
bronchoconstriction and glandular
secretions and that's how the all
allergic symptoms inflammation pain it
it evokes so I hope you enjoyed this
video and in this video we described all
the subtypes of the antibodies and their
functions their abundance in our body so
if you liked this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you